par ailleurs vous dites dans votre livre
qu'il faut déculpabiliser se
déculpabiliser alors il suffit de
prendre au hasard alors là je tombe sur
un des conseils que vous donnez dont je
rappelle un appel 150 ils sont listés et
là je tombe sur le numéro 152 je fais de
la zumba pour arrêter de crier alors
c'est très sympa et je vous avoue que ça
m'a fait sourire en le lisant
mais est ce que réellement c'est une
astuce qui est d'abord faisable parce
qu'on a des horaires parfois compliqué
et est ce que réellement ça va nous
aider à des clips déculpabiliser voyez
ce que je veux dans ce genre d'accord
justement l'idée c'est d'aller de marée
à chacune quel est son petit truc je
sais pas vous valez par exemple c'est
quoi votre petit truc très josé dont je
peux je vois la sas et ça pourrait très
bien une astuce qui fait partie du livre
est en fait l'idée s'est demandé à
chacune vraiment quel est son astuce
zoom pour certaines ça va être ça pour
d'autres ça va écrire pour d'autres
encore ça va être autre chose
mais l'idée dans ce livre c'est d'avoir
à la fois des astuces très pratique en
même temps des choses qui sont de
l'ordre du droit pour mieux peser
justement ces droits mieux les faire
valoir mieux savoir vers quel réseau
institutionnel on va pouvoir se tourner
et puis des petites choses rigolotes que
nous on dit là des mères qui travaillent
qui sont assez inspirante et qui ont
partagé des choses vraiment du quotidien
petit au 1er il ya à la fois l'aspect
effectivement législatif et puis le
pragmatique et pratique de ce qu'on peut
vivre au quotidien
ludivine justement sur cet aspect
pragmatique exactement alors votre livre
si tout ce que j'aime
il est drôle il pratique il est fils
good c'est l'avis même des mamans qui
racontait je suis mère donc je suis bien
placé pour en parler avec les fameux
faux bons conseils souvent pas que l'on
nous donne
mais mon chapitre préféré c'est celui
que vient d'ailleurs d'évoquer valérie
sur le fait de déculpabiliser alors vous
donner les astuces des unes et des
autres d'ailleurs pour y parvenir mais
vous ne donne cher pas quelles ont été
vos astuces pour réussir à
déculpabiliser alors il faut le rappeler
vous êtes maman oui tout aveuglait g29
12 ans et 7 ans et moi je les ai eu
assez jeune j'étais la première mon
groupe d'amis avoir des enfants que j'ai
expérimenté j'ai essuyé les plâtres pour
un peu mes amis voici exactement ras
lanouf avait de quoi je parle moi je
dirais que ce qui est important c'est
vraiment super man 2 pas je crois que je
lis tu d'ailleurs au début les conseils
à pas être suivre où les fourgons oui il
ya le fameux faux bon ben voila et je
pense que justement l'idée c'est de se
demander ce qui est bon pour soi et pas
ce qui est bon pour les autres il ya
toujours quand on est maire on va
toujours être jugé il suffit de regarder
la par exemple meghan markle qui vient
d'accoucher magazine people fnn ans
m'ont rempli d'articles pour dire est ce
qu'elle va bientôt perdre ses kilos elle
qu'elle valait l'été est ce qu'elle va
donner du bruit j'ai vu un article de la
presse quotidienne régionale qui mettait
elle affiche ses rondeurs
alors que ce ne sont pas des m'as sauté
aux yeux donc exactement et du coup
l'idée c'est d'arriver à se défaire de
ses injonctions et je pense que partager
la sororité la solidarité féminine
partagés au sein d'un réseau avec
d'autres mamans pour voir qu'en fait
c'est pas un sujet individuel mais c'est
vraiment un sujet de société un sujet
politique collectif qui concerne
l'ensemble des femmes mais aussi des
hommes